ja wir schauen in die Ukraine schlechten
Form und schlecht ausgebildet
Kanonenfutter so hat die Ukraine zuletzt
häufiger und Präsident selenski jetzt
wieder die russischen Soldaten
bezeichnet die Putin zu Verstärkung an
die Frontlinien im Osten und Süden der
Ukraine entsandt hat ja gleichzeitig
warnt der ukrainische Präsident aber
auch die schiere Anzahl der russischen
Soldaten die würde die militärischen
Erfolge der Ukraine doch in die Länge
ziehen
jetzt schickt Russland tausende seiner
mobilisierten Männer an die Front sie
haben keine nennenswerte militärische
Ausbildung so eine Ausbildung werden Sie
allerdings überhaupt nicht benötigen es
wird nämlich erwartet dass die
mobilisierten Russen den Krieg
mindestens ein paar Wochen überleben
können es wird erwartet dass sie sterben
und neue werden an die Front geschickt
die russischen Generäle benutzen ihre
Leute als Kanonenfutter um zusätzlichen
Druck auf unsere Verteidiger auszuüben
es ist ein spürbarer Druck und ich bin
all unseren Soldaten dankbar die das
ertragen
und er ist der wichtigste Mann hinter
Präsident selenski Michael podoljak der
Berater des ukraine-präsidenten Bild hat
ihn exklusiv in Kiew getroffen und wir
haben ihn nach einer der größten Sorgen
der freien Welt gefragt wird Kreml
Tyrann Putin nuklearbomben also
Atombomben in seinem blutigen Kampf
gegen die Ukraine einsetzen
wir gehen nicht davon aus dass Russland
die Atomwaffen auch nicht die taktischen
einsetzen wird die Bedrohung wurde
weniger das geht aus unseren
Geheimdienstinformationen hervor und
unsere Partner sagen das gleiche allen
ist klar dass sie Russland eine klare
Antwort geben müssen wer Atomwaffen
einsetzen will wird eine entsprechende
Antwort erhalten und Russland scheint
das zu verstehen wir sehen auch einen
starken Rückgang der nuklearen Bedrohung
in der russischen Rhetorik wobei wir da
die Propagandisten ausklammern müssen
und nur über die Beamten sprechen Virus
wir sehen einen starken Rückgang der
Bedrohung mit Atomwaffen und das ist ein
ziemlich gutes Zeichen
russland hat zugegeben dass es einen
konventionellen Krieg führen kann aber
jeder Versuch Atomwaffen einzusetzen
wird zu einem sofortigen Gegenschlag
führen
ja und wann endet dieser Krieg wie kann
dieser Krieg enden auch dafür findet der
präsidentenberater klare Worte
dieser Krieg hat einen nicht linearen
Verlauf wenn die Umstände stimmen kann
er schon im Winter Enden das sind die
Meinungen in Europa die Bereitschaft zur
Niederlage Russlands und den
Waffenlieferungen
wir sind uns darüber im Klaren dass dies
nicht über Nacht geschehen kann selbst
wenn wir heute beschließen dass wir eine
bestimmte Menge an Waffen benötigen
heißt das nicht dass sie morgen auf
Lager sind und übermorgen auf dem
Schlachtfeld in der Ukraine stehen es
geht auch um die Frage ob die Ukraine
bereit ist zu gewinnen und das ist sie
die Ukraine ist bereit zu gewinnen wenn
alles richtig läuft dann kann der Krieg
im Winter oder im Frühjahr 2023 enden
[Musik]
gehen wir in die Ukraine zu Björn
Stritzel nach hakif Björn selensky sagt
der Druck auf die ukrainischen
Verteidiger da wird größer was heißt das
jetzt konkret für die Ukraine
also die Mobilisierung die Russland ja
vor einigen Wochen vollzogen hat dem
zusätzlichen Einzug von mehreren
zehntausenden Soldaten der sorgt
natürlich dafür dass ich die russische
Frontlinie zumindest etwas stabilisiert
ist ja hier im Park ist in der Region
Parkett zusammengebrochen durch die
ukrainische Offensive aber nach und nach
kommen wird eben die russischen Kräfte
an und die da sollte man sich vielleicht
auch nicht zu sehr von einzelnen Videos
leiten lassen wo wir russische Soldaten
betrunken sehen oder mit rostigen
gewähren das ist natürlich nur ein
Ausschnitt sozusagen der russischen
Verstärkung die dort ankommen
letztendlich ist es da die Masse die
dann doch dafür sorgt so wenig kompetent
die da vielleicht auch im Einzelnen sein
mögen die da eben doch dafür sorgt dass
ich die Frontlinie etwas stabilisiert
und gleichzeitig haben die ukrainischen
Verteidiger natürlich auch erstmal
müssen auch erstmal ihre Kräfte wieder
auffrischen müssen auch erstmal wieder
rotieren insofern ist diese Offensive
die dort vor einigen Wochen große große
Gebiete befreit hat jetzt zum Stillstand
gekommen aber das natürlich dass da der
die Geschwindigkeit etwas abnimmt und
den rasonnen Süden des Landes dort
stehen die ukrainischen Verteidiger auch
noch vor dem vor der Schwierigkeit dass
die russische Armee sich dort relativ
geordnet zurückgezogen hat wir haben
dort nicht wie ein arkes und Mengen an
Material und Menschenleben verloren
sondern sie haben sich relativ geordnet
zurückgezogen und können damit halt ihre
Verteidigungslinie zumindest etwas
besser konsolidieren als sie das konnten
du hast dir ja mehrere befreite Dörfer
angeschaut was hast du da erlebt was
sagen die Menschen wie froh sind sie
darüber dass ihre Soldaten dass die
Ukraine wieder da sind
also wir waren gestern in einem
breitendorf in Sichtweite der russischen
Grenze auf ukrainischer Seite und dort
sind natürlich überwiegt zwar die Freude
darüber dass jetzt die russischen
Besatzer weg sind allerdings von den
früher 300 in 300 Einwohnern sind nur
vier momentan die dort im dorflebenste
Grund ist dass es dort kein Elektrizität
kein Wasser kein kein Gas gibt das ein
Großteil des Ortes zerstört ist und was
nach einem schwersten liegt was uns
immer wieder gesagt wurde ist sind die
russischen Gruppen haben vor ihrem
Absicht Felder und die gesamte Umgebung
verdient die das ukrainische Militär bzw
der ukrainische Zivilschutz konnten
bisher nur Straßen und Gebäude entnehmen
und es fehlt eben an an Spezialisten an
entsprechendem Gerät und diese um diese
Orte auch wirklich wieder ja gewohnbar
und lebbar und ungefährlich zu machen
auch für Kinder die Familien mit Kindern
wieder zurückkehren wollen
das wird wahrscheinlich noch lange Zeit
dauern eben aufgrund dieser dieser
waldflächigen Vermietung
live aus der Ukraine ganz herzlichen
Dank an dich
ja und während der Krieg weiter tobt gab
es unterdessen einen ganz besonderen
Gipfel einen Gipfel der Diktatoren
Despoten und Machthaber ein Gipfel mit
Putin der gerade ja den grausamen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine führt
mit dem iranischen mularaisi der Frauen
in seinem Land verfolgt Demonstranten
einsperrt und Gegner verfolgt und auch
dabei der türkische Staatschef Erdogan
der einzig westliche Politiker mit dem
Creme Diktator Putin überhaupt noch
spricht ein Gipfel der Tyrannen also ein
Gipfel der Konferenz für Zusammenarbeit
und vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen in
Asien so der offizielle Titel tja und
das macht man bei so einem
tyrannengipfel Tischtennis spielen
Ping Pong Diplomatie Erdogan vergnügt
beim Tischtennis in Astana
in einem von der türkischen
Nachrichtenagentur Anadolu ajansi
verbreiteten Video liefert sich
Präsident Recep Tayyip Erdogan am Rande
eines Gipfels in der kasachischen
Hauptstadt Astana ein tischtennismatch
mit seinem kasachischen Amtskollegen K7
schumach Türkei die beiden Staatsmänner
spielen mit Hemd und Krawatte unter
einem pompösen Kronleuchter
für Aufmerksamkeit sorgt die eigenartige
Schlägerhaltung Erdogan auf dem Video
ist zu sehen wie Erdogan statt des
Griffes das Schlägerblatt hält offenbar
ist das eine Standard Haltung des
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan nimmt in
Astana am Gipfel der Konferenz für
Zusammenarbeit und vertrauensbildende
Maßnahmen in Asien Teil auch ein Treffen
mit creme-chef Wladimir Putin ist
geplant
[Musik]
wer das Spiel gewonnen hat das wissen
wir nicht aber es gab dann tatsächlich
noch ein ja inhaltliches Treffen
zwischen Erdogan und Putin die beiden
Staatsoberhäupter haben sich über ja
russischen Angaben zufolge nicht über
die Lösung des Ukraine Konflikts
ausgetauscht eine Einigung zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine war kein Thema
zitiert die staatliche
Nachrichtenagentur RIA den Sprecher
Putins
[Musik]